Jeff Mauro is the definition of
celebrity chef as host of two Emmy
nominated cooking shows the food
network's sandwich king and they talk
show the kitchen growing up in Chicago
he had a natural gift for entertaining
keeping his family laughing while
exploring his love for food his first
job was in a sandwich shop eating a lot
they're decent MIT never looked back
also taking the stage as Tony in the
Chicago production of the hit comedy
Tony and Tina's Wedding last year People
magazine named him one of the sexiest
chefs in America that's a good title
along with his thriving TV career he
launched pork and Mindy's his growing
fast casual Chicago area concept and
there was plenty more but first we want
to welcome chef Jeff Mauro to the dish
good morning thank you guys for having
me
we've been drooling since sitting down
what exactly do we have on the table
this is this is very exciting for us we
have some of our pork and Mindy's
standard bestsellers here for you we got
our sweet potato potato salad
traditional potato salad made with sweet
potatoes our smoked beans we use three
beans fresh poblanos everything we got
our famous golden tots and ranch made
with our homemade buttermilk dill ranch
we make in-house you dip that in there
it's like the best fries now we have our
famous pig candy which is our crispy
caramelized brown sugar coated slow
smoked bacon candy
pig pig candy and our debut here our
hand-cut put straw Mindy sandwich so
this is the best pastrami you ever have
on a on a beautiful ride bun marble rye
bun that we butter we griddle right so
it's toasty and buttery we put some of
our pnm mustard sauce and some of our
pickles on there
simplicity beautiful uncha sness you
bite it your mouth just wants to just
sit there and literally hug your tongue
and for a drink I made you a cocktail
here this is a mezcal Arita made with
fresh watermelon juice some muddled
Fresno chilies
you mentioned pork and Minnie's a bunch
this is relatively new right this is
about eight months old so it's my first
well I have a baby my son Lorenzo is my
first baby but this is my second child
it's the first place I put my name on
I'm there when I'm not traveling or
shooting I'm there I'm hands-on all the
time and it is you
it's I'd like to say it's in its you
know terrible two stage right now so I'm
loving it I think people seeing you here
so many people recognize you from the
Food Network I would have been mad if
you did not bring a sandwich I know
that's I would have been bad bad bad
news where did your love of cooking
start cause your family a lot of people
are chefs in the family you know very
true I think it all stems from my mom
and my my her three sisters my aunts and
we all grew up with this census big
italian-american family with the sense
of that food is used in any celebration
no matter how big or small right every
graduation party tons of food every
birthday just layers and layers and
trays of food my mom you know is a great
cook it's just funny now that we I've
gone to culinary school and have been
professional we often bought heads now
in the kitchen because you tell me well
I thought I do but she does not mistake
set instruction you know she tries to
tell me how she's been doing it for
years so we learned from each other you
know often tumultuous moms are always
right they're always right what you
you're very you are very big on the
sandwich I am and this is a very good
one hey we just try to what is it about
the sandwich that that sort of gets you
you know what I think it's just the most
familiar vehicle for sustenance in the
world right
since the Earl of Sandwich invented this
thing in the 1800s you know over a card
game where he didn't want to use two
hands at once you know playing cards we
needed to eat with one and look at his
cards with the other it came from you
know simplicity and necessity and I
think that's you know the best part
about this no matter where you on the
world what country will continent what
culture has their own version of the
sandwich it's no longer it looked as
just you know a turkey club sandwich
that you know is built out of necessity
and that you stuff in a brown bag for
lunch this is now a composed culinary
experience it's like the most simplistic
things are usually the hardest to
execute correctly it's very true and
this is affordable you know this is yeah
eight nine bucks and you could still
have that kind of culinary adventure
without having to spend $40 on a prix
fixe meal you know it's not this is for
everybody and I'm the kind of guy that's
for everybody I grew up for everybody
and hopefully and I kind of look like a
sandwich
well I need us to go to break so I can
take a proper bite of this big sandwich
as we hand you this dish
thank you so much if you could have this
meal with any person pastor president
who would that person you know I got a
lot of family I love all my family I eat
with them constantly but it would be
Chris Farley because he was like my idol
growing up I was an SNL aficionado I
still am into him he was like the chubby
fat kid in class that I always was who
had to kind of get by making people
laugh he was he was to me the funniest
person the most jovial Midwestern guy
genius just a genius so that's right and
I loved each I'm sure the guy would be a
heck of a needy drinking partner from
what I heard well you I'm sure you
notice the shout out we gave him in the
show earlier so obviously big fans we
did he was in one of our pieces really I
swear I didn't see that I'm not poaching
on your material here I'm all original
thank ordinated and more on Jeff and the
dish please head to our website at CBS
this morning calm